[Music]
we have a great talk for you Kara
we've been talking to care about of
course Kara has written about long now
that's part of her book and so we've
been plotting and scheming on this for
quite a while so for tonight's talk
Kara's Kara's book which I don't have a
copy of with but we have her book for
sale we have the technology in in the
back and she'll be signing after the
talk there there it is is as you're
gonna hear looking at the way that
humans are looking into the future
extending and expanding the ways that we
are human from from what's at the core
and I think what's what's really
remarkable about this book is it really
documents the science but also the
individuals the personalities that are
driving the quests to follow human
curiosity and expand what's at the core
of the way we experience the world so
let's give a big round of applause for
Kara as she leads us into that world now
okay am I on I'm on hello friends a
little long now I'm so excited to be
here I love this place
so let me make sure that this is working
oh yeah okay that's me so I fully accept
that nobody has any idea who I am so
these are usually the questions that
people want to know which is who are you
and how the heck did you report this
monster so I am a science journalist I
teach at UC Berkeley in the Graduate
School of Journalism and I essentially
took a year off to go out and I sofa
surfed the world to report this book I'm
not a cognitive scientist I'm not a
psychologist I'm not a neuroscientist
but I thought those people were really
amazing and so what I wanted to do is
not only bring their labs to you but
bring the science of people who are
doing things out in the real world
outside of the laboratory so what I did
was I posted on Facebook and I said hey
guys I want to go to this military base
in Colorado anybody got a couch in
Colorado okay hey guys I want to go to
Paris because some people are doing
something really cool in a hospital in
Paris and it worked so I went to eight
US states and four countries sofa
surfing on people and I thought I could
go for surfing on people's couches and I
thought I can show you in two minutes
where I went and what I did so I went
here and I went here anybody know what
that is
that is it where they keep the atomic
clock it's where time comes from I went
here I went here this is Monell chemical
senses Center this is kind of like the
wonka factory for smell and taste
research I went to a lot of places that
look like this I went here this is me
driving a virtual Humvee I'm in virtual
reality so that's virtual Iraq I went
here which maybe some of you have seen
in San Francisco I went here this is
when I was researching bionic eyes I
just happen to draw drive by the sign
that said percept and I thought that's a
sign and here and here that's the
toasters but it's in London so if you
can see it says T because T is and here
in here and I smelled this thing and I
smelled those things and I drank that
thing and I wore that thing and I
unfortunately wore that thing and I wore
those things
and I met this robot part which is meant
to help this robot anybody know what
that is it's a surgeon yeah so that it's
for use for robotic surgery I met this
very old computer anybody know what this
little computer is yeah very good
it's in order to understand that very
new computer which is standing right
behind you I got these these are
augmented reality to tattoos they
animate in a mirror I got a lot of shots
I turned a lot of stuff that looks like
this into stuff that looks like this
and I turned these into those and I
turned these into that and I drank a lot
of this which is black blood of the
earth the most caffeinated coffee on
earth yeah and that's what I did to my
computer I don't know if you can see it
but those keys aren't just worn off
they're actually cratered and I did that
to my wrist and I did that to my couch
and at one point my students took pity
on me and sent me this care package
those are thinking socks I had hair
really good students and finally this
happened and then this happened which is
the last phase of the edit and then this
happened which is the debut of the giant
head my cover art and finally here we
are now so that's it all right so what's
inside the giant head so here I want to
give you just a quick overview of what
I'm not gonna talk about tonight before
I get into what I am going to talk about
right so this book is about sensory
perception in other words it's about the
experience that your head creates for
you of the world right and how you can
hack it and the starting point of this
book on page 2 basically is the idea
that there is no one single reality and
once you get over that idea the rest of
the book is just a long coast downhill
right so what I mean by that is there's
no one single concrete experience that
we all share and when you think about it
that makes sense because we're all
genetically different our bodies and our
brains are all different but it also
makes sense because perception is
extremely malleable right your brain has
to deal with much more information than
it could process individually so your
brain has to filter and the way you
filter the way you learn to attend to
certain things is different there are a
lot of factors that change that and most
of all your senses are limited so we
only have five portals right you have
sight you have sound you have smell
taste and touch but we know that there's
more information in the world that we
can't pick up how do we know because
other animals can sense it right so
sharks can sense the electricity we
can't we don't have the right gear we
only see the spectrum we call visible
light but we know that there's more
information outside of it there's the
infrared which some kinds of animals
like the pit viper can sense and there's
the ultraviolet which the honeybee can
sense helps them land on the right
flower right and we know that there are
magnetic fields and lots of animals that
migrate north-south can sense magnetic
fields right sea turtles certain kinds
of fish the monarch butterfly
there's even evidence that some kind of
bacteria can do that not because they
migrate but because they need to orient
themselves in the mud that they live in
right so when I met with a group of
biohackers called grindhouse wetware
they're out in Pennsylvania they were
really mad about this they were
frustrated right they were saying why
can't we sense the infrared right what's
so great about the mantis shrimp and the
honeybee right why couldn't we see a
sunset in infrared and ultraviolet so
they and other people like them are
experimenting on their own bodies
they're trying to expand or enhance
their senses and they were kind of an
extreme of the people that I met but
they were part of a much broader field
of endeavor right these are this is a
book it's 11 stories about people who
are all pushing the limits of sensory
perception so I met soldiers I met
surgeons I met perfumers I met Pickler's
I met clockmaker some of them in this
room I met I met people who build robots
and I met neuroscientists right and let
me give you an example of some of the
people I met I met Dean Lloyd who's one
of the first people on the planet who
has ever relearned how to see he
volunteered to receive one of the first
retinal implants so Dean was born with
vision he lost it as an adult because he
developed a disease called retinitis
pigmentosa he volunteered for this study
to have a chip that is actually inside
the back of his eyeball that translates
images from a camera into electronic
signals that give him a perception of
vision so he had to relearn how to see
it's not what he saw before but it's
enough that he can get around and that
sherry Ren who is the surgeon who drives
that surgical robot you saw and I
watched her remove somebody's
gallbladder from the other side of the
room and the amazing thing about that is
that robot gives her no touch feedback
she's doing it all visually but there
are mechanical engineers who are trying
to give her that sense of touch back and
the reason it's important is not just
for robotic surgery but because enabling
a haptic robotic limb that can not only
move but touch is the step that you need
in order to develop a thought-controlled
neuroprosthetic limb that can grasp and
render touch feedback in real-time right
so a person knows what they're picking
up they know how hard they're gripping
it I went to military base in Colorado
that's where you saw me driving the
Humvee to learn about using virtual
reality to treat post-traumatic stress
disorder the idea is can you create a
virtual environment so real that it
tricks the mind into healing can you
really
to a traumatic situation in VR and have
them heal from that and in fact when I
was there they were trying to pretreat
soldiers now they were working with a
group that was about to deploy and the
idea is can we put you in traumatic
situations now teach you coping
mechanisms in VR and then see if it
makes you less likely to develop PTSD
when you come back right so this book is
called we have the technology I make the
argument that technology does not only
mean stuff that lights up even though
that's cool so some of the chapters are
about other things that have to do with
different kinds of technologies some
chapter about smell is about a group at
a hospital in Paris that's using perfume
to help people with Alzheimer's recover
lost memories because it turns out that
differentiating between different scents
is the first clinical symptom of
Alzheimer's also of Parkinson's disease
the chapter of pain is about medicine
specifically tylenol the idea is can you
use a painkiller that's meant for
physical pain for the pain of social
rejection in other words does your brain
process the pain of a broken heart and
the pain of a broken bone this
same way the answer so far seems to be
yes right so for what I wanted to talk
to you about tonight it's a different
kind of technology and I think you're
going to get it my story starts with the
scent the search for a sixth taste and
it starts here at the Denver Museum of
Nature and Science and yes those are
child sized lab coats the most adorable
thing in the universe so this is a
really great museum the kids get to do
all these things where they they like
can extract the DNA from wheat germ they
can measure how much sugar they have in
cereals the the part of the lab that I
was in was around the corner in this
thing called the genetics of taste lab
and this is a citizen science powered
lab so my guide for the day was a
retired dentist named Mark Mike Archer
and this was the stuff we had to work
with so this is a DNA swab this is where
I donated my DNA to science those are
some oyster crackers and some water in
case I tasted something that was very
repellant that is a timer and I will
tell you about the rest of it it will
make sense in a minute so oh wait one
more thing these these are my nose plugs
very important in taste research because
it ensures that you can smell you can
taste but you can't smell so Mike Archer
when I met him he's wearing this very
dentist like lab coat and I say why do
you have it he says other kids like it
right but even though the lab coat was
kind of for show the science that we
were about to do there was real if it
works it's going to shed some light on
one of the biggest mysteries and sensory
science which is we're going to see if I
can taste fat right not bacon not cream
fat right specifically dispatch this is
linoleic acid this is an omega-6
polyunsaturated fatty acid and taste
researchers who are investigating this
think there are pretty good reasons why
humans should be able to taste fat so
it's essential to our food supply it's
used by the brain it's used by the
immune system they say there's a good
reason why your body should be able to
pick it out in its environment right so
scientists currently divide
into five basics or primaries this will
look very familiar to you I'm sure salty
sweet bitter umami also known as savory
and sour right and these are considered
the building blocks of taste things that
you cannot break apart you cannot
subdivide just the way on the color
wheel blue or red are considered
primaries or basics right a scientist
said to me you cannot subdivide sweet
sweetness as a thing unto itself right
but some of you might remember those of
you who like me went to school in the
last century remember a time when there
was only four right so this idea of
umami or savory only made the list in
the year 2000 for people who are still
like what is that it's usually the
flavor that's associated with things
very savory things like Parmesan cheese
caramelized onions a slow-cooked tomato
paste would be considered umami so
that's in the United States this concept
was actually stud was actually named in
1908 in Japan by a scientist named dr.
kunai Ikeda who said it is a fifth taste
and it's associated with the amino acid
glutamate right just the way sugar is
associated with sweets salt with salt
he says glutamate is what's responsible
for MSG when this was accepted in the
Western world around the year 2000 it
kind of upended the taste research world
right if there were five now why not six
one at seven why not a thousand right
it's kind of like where we are right now
with taste research if the we're
astronomy was at the end of the 17th
century when astronomers were like oh
okay Jupiter what if there's something
out beyond Jupiter right what if our
system is bigger than we thought it was
so fat is championed by dr. Rick mattis
who's a nutrition scientist at Purdue
University and what's weird is there is
actually no list of what you have to do
to be considered a basic tastes so he
made one which people like so here's the
basic ideas first of all has to be a
receptor for it on the tongue there has
to be something that locks with a
certain molecule and they believe there
are two four fatty acids
they're called C D 36 and GPR 120 okay
nerves it has to get to the brain along
the right nervous
pathway it has to go along the gustatory
nerve so this is tricky because your
mouth also has nerves and it's part of
me
your mouth also has nerves in it for
touch when it comes to food this is what
we call mouthfeel right that thing's
feel creamy or they feel crunchy or
whatever and people sometimes say why
isn't spicy a basic taste or why isn't
cool a basic taste it's because that's
actually touch it's a feeling it's
actually pain in the case of spiciness
okay has to have a purpose I know I
wrote that in yellow so nobody can see
it it has to have a purpose and the idea
is well not not everybody agrees with it
but usually they'll say okay basic
tastes are either attractive or aversive
so the idea with sweet this is
attractive it shows you where the
calories are so you want to eat it the
idea with you mommy is that shows you
where the protein is it's what amino
acids are in so that's good to eat it
bitter things are usually poisonous
toxic so don't eat it
with salt and with sourness people
disagree but they think it's either a
matter of concentration or satiety in
other words you like a little bit but
you don't like a lot or you like it when
you your body needs it and then you
reject it when it's too much okay must
have a physiological reaction this one's
a little bit trickier so madis says your
body has to do something in reaction to
it with fat a lot of fats are these
giant blocks called triglycerides
mattis's there is a salivary enzyme that
called lipase that basically chips free
fatty acids off this big block that's
what can lock into the receptors on your
tongue
they know that mice make this this
enzyme and they can taste fat because
when they block it my stop preferring
the fat right but do humans have it and
so in his human experience experiments
what he does is he makes people too hard
fats like coconut and soft fats like
olive oil and then he measures how much
lipase they produce so chew the hard fat
you salivate more you get more this
white paste there that he says it's the
physiological reaction alright here's
the thing we care about can anybody
actually sense the darn thing right and
can they can they actually distinguish
it from the other five that we have so
that's why I went to the museum right
and that's where
you come in we're gonna try an
experiment based on the museum's
experiment we're gonna see if this works
we're gonna see if people can taste fat
so Michael do you have the fat strips
queued up somewhere yeah okay awesome
so the the museum was very very kind to
send us some examples of the fat strips
that I tried we're gonna see if this
works because they have traveled a great
distance and success is not guaranteed
so don't eat anything yet I'm gonna tell
you what we're gonna do yeah all right
we'll see if this happens so um so what
you'll see in these cups when you get it
is an almost invisible little strip it
looked to me kind of like onion skin
this has has anybody ever used a melt
melt away breath strip before yeah this
is the same thing except instead of
having like mouthwash in it it has
linoleic acid these are a little crumbly
if you find one that's broken that's
okay all that matters is that you taste
it so does everybody have one there's
still some more coming up okay we're
gonna see if this works okay so so
here's how it's gonna go
don't do it quite yet but I don't have
nose clips for you so you're gonna have
to yes exactly do this mimic it yourself
then plug your nose put the fat strip
and you want it to be pretty back pretty
far on your tongue and then we're just
gonna let it dissolve for 45 seconds
right 45 seconds and just see what you
see
okay now before it's gone unplug your
nose and see if that changes anything
for you
all right that's 45 all right anybody
taste anything yeah what'd you get all
right yeah okay
anybody else sorry
like like meat Oh interesting
yeah okay sorry did you did you see
something right here yeah okay all right
Oh candle wax interesting ha ha chickens
again okay anybody else get anything
that was really different I love it did
for anybody did you find the experience
change when you unplug your nose yeah so
for people how did it change for those
of you where it changed yeah well it is
it is on this wafer thing right yeah
who's that bitter bitter bitter bitter
uh this is that you're my people right
cuz that's the experience I had to but
this is real man this is so interesting
okay so I'm really glad it worked I was
a little bit worried that the strips
might not have survived the journey
okay so here's why I said plug your nose
first and then and then afterwards it's
because this is the grossest picture I
could find if what the inside of your
head looks like found this on a doctor's
office so what most people think of as
taste is actually more accurately called
flavor it's the combined work of the
nose and the mouth working together so
when you eat basically scent molecules
kind of travel up this back passageway
to your nose and your brain processes
them in combination this is why when you
have a cold food really sucks right
because you can't you're you're not
getting that half of the equation right
so here's what happened
when I always let them use them what did
you sense we had a whole wide variety of
experiences here this was my first
reaction I was with the people who said
bitter but here's the problem that is
already another basic taste right so
they said okay guess again and I said
acid and the problem is that's already
essentially another basic taste right
and here is where I ran into the second
secret purpose of the Museum study it
wasn't to see if people can taste fat it
was to see if we can describe how fat
tastes because it turns out this isn't
necessarily a biochemistry problem it's
a word problem right the technology here
for taste is language yeah right so this
is a really interesting idea so the
problem hinges on this how can you
perceive something if you don't have a
word and therefore an established
concept for it right so in order to
recognize a new basic taste our tongue
is not going to change in our lifetimes
but our minds can we can learn to
discern a separate unique quality in the
foods that we've been eating all along
and there's actually a sensory science
precedent for this it has to do with the
world of vision it's the idea of
isolating a new color did any of you
ever blow your minds when you were a kid
by trying to figure out what a new color
might be I totally have right so the
idea is there are certain cultures in
the world where the language has not
built separate words for blue and for
green it doesn't mean that people can't
see both blue and green it doesn't mean
their eye is different doesn't mean they
can't perceive that wavelength it means
when they're looking at this rainbow
they perceive blue and green as one
experience and people who have a
language that separates blue and green
perceive them as two do we have any
Russian speakers here tonight I was at I
was speaking out this with somebody who
is a native Russian speaker and she said
actually in Russian we split blue into
two different words two different
concepts one that's kind of a cyan and
one that's kind of an indigo blue and
those to us would be two discrete
categories of things right there was a
German philosopher ger who did this very
interesting research in the 19th century
where he examined ancient texts from
various languages and he's
that language is tended to develop words
for colors in the same order so it's
black and white first then red then
yellow then green the blue right and at
the time he thought maybe this is
actually anatomical evolution maybe
people's eyes are actually changing but
today people read it as no it's actually
either a cultural or linguistic
adaptation either people have come up
with the concept of the color invent or
an invented a word for it or the other
way around they've invented the word and
learn to perceive the color as separate
right and where you are kind of depends
on where you are in that debate
so maybe fat has been in the taste
rainbow all along and we just don't have
the word to pick it out right we default
to its nearest neighbor which for some
of us might have been bitter or sour and
for some of you might have been meteor
savory or something like oh mommy right
so when I talked to dr. Nicole Garneau
who's the Denver museum's curator of
human health she's the person who set up
this experiment she said oh this is a
total word problem we couldn't even put
out a press release it was hard to
figure out what to call this thing right
they ended up calling it fatty acid
taste but she says it's accurate but but
what does it mean nobody cares nobody
has a mental perceptor what fatty acid
should taste like so what they're doing
at the Museum is essentially
crowdsourcing so they don't just ask you
can you taste it they ask you to
describe how it tastes the idea is can
the 1,500 people who undertake this
experiment kind of collectively come up
with other words that other people will
recognize for how fat tastes right so
here were my very helpful contributions
to taste sight science for taste
these were my words cleaner solvents and
PVC pipes you know I immediately went to
metaphor I could not think of an
adjective for it and for the smell it
was shoe polish stale air and luggage
that was as close as I got I asked them
if they would share with me their
preliminary results so here are the
results from the first about 700 people
as of last April so the top three for
taste were bitter buttery and nothing
which is actually pretty much like what
people said in this room right and for a
smell it was nothing
paper and cardboard which again is very
much like what some people have said in
this room and I said okay give me the
outliers I want to know
weird once and the rotation was rotten
icing ocean water dandelions and gummy
bears and for smelly it was seaweed
pine nuts stamp books and bricks right
so why why might there be this oh I
should say also there was an extra phase
of the experiment we did at the Museum
that we couldn't replicate here that we
did what's called scaling tests they
gave us four-way first that each had a
different amount of the linoleic acid in
it including some that were the placebo
they had nothing and then they would say
rate it on a scale of 0 to 10 how strong
is this taste and from those scaling
tests they found out yeah actually
people are very good at accurately
saying which ones are stronger and which
ones are weaker and they actually found
that women and girls were more sensitive
and for a reason I can't explain kids
seem to be better at picking it out than
adults were so possibly one reason for
this variation at least gender variation
is the gene that's related to it so the
CD 36 gene has eighty four thousand base
pairs that is really gnarly and huge and
by contrast the TAS to our 38 gene which
is one of the genes involved in bitter
only has about a thousand so that's a
lot of opportunities for differences in
in mutation or gene expression right for
the record I asked dr. Richter Richard
mattis if he could describe that how fat
tastes and this is what he said he said
no no I can't
it's awful period it sucks the air out
of your lungs it's just terrible
nauseating it's rancidity
it's really really bad cooking oil the
sensation that gives you and he says at
first most people default to something
like bitter but he says he doesn't think
that's actually the word it's just a way
of saying that is bad right so and I
said okay why why do we why did this be
so gross especially because most fatty
foods if you think about it are very
very pleasant to eat right like ice
cream was Graham bacon right and he says
okay fat the texture of fat the
mouthfeel of fat should be pleasant
because we need to eat fat that's good
for us but free fatty acids are
generated when food spoils and he says
so it should be aversive you should
actually no no I I don't want to eat
this it could make me sick
now there's another x-factor which is
that people are enormous least
adjustable when it comes to the flavor
of things and dr. Garneau is she's a
geneticist her background is in yeasts
so she works with a lot of winemakers
and and beer makers and she goes to a
lot of events where there was wine and
beer and she was telling me a story
about she and her husband were at a wine
tasting and her husband just to see what
would happen said uh this is a real
gunpowder quality to it and then to her
horror other people in the room started
saying oh yes yes I can taste the
Gunpowder right and she says he says
when when somebody tosses out an
unlikely term when you're trying to
figure out a taste you're gonna latch
onto it your brains gonna be like yes
that's it because I can't come up with
the language and that's just for things
that are familiar like wine when we're
faced with a potential six basic tastes
a really abstract concept she says now
we're talking about a topic we literally
have no language about so it's
compounded your brain wants to solve
your brain so much wants to solve this
puzzle of what it's tasting and it
doesn't have the language so whatever
anyone throws out there you're gonna be
like yes that is it right so that's what
they're up against I want to just give
you a couple of other ideas very briefly
that I introduced in this chapter which
is one of the other problem that they're
up against is that taste science like
most sciences that have to do with
perception used to be about the mind
they used to be psychological and
behavioral sciences so the way you
studied these things is you took a
person or an animal and you gave them a
stimulus and then you saw what happened
right so with food you would give them a
food and then you would see do they like
it do they eat more of it do they avoid
it do they spit it out right within the
last two decades this became an almost
entirely biochemical science the whole
idea of what people are studying moved
from the brain from what happens in the
mind to what happens on the tongue this
moment when a chemical locks into a
receptor it's a huge shift all of the
people that I talked to had trained in
behavioral science and psychology and
now we're working in a biochemical world
so the first family of bitter receptors
was only described in the year 2000 and
when I say family there are actually 25
of them and there's this cool debate
going on right now
taste science world where they say look
it's 25 receptors does that mean there
are 25 different bidders right could we
learn to discriminate between say like
the bitter of alcohol the bitter of
quinine the bitterness of vegetables
right that is a really interesting
question that the field is wrestling
with right now so the receptor for sweet
only came along in the year 2001 the
ones for umami came along in the year
2000 and 2002 and that was kind of the
thing that clinched it for everybody
everybody said this this idea this crazy
idea that people in Japan have been
talking about for a century it's real we
can prove it because we found a receptor
and that's what unleashed the hunt for
the sixth taste right so here are some
of the other contenders that I went out
to taste this is calcium which once
again is something that your body needs
for your immune system for bones water
there are people who say water is a
taste a unique taste of its own carbon
dioxide there are some labs that are
working into whether you can taste it
separate from the texture of carbonation
bubbles this is this really weird
mystery this is some pali coast that
something only rats and mice can taste
so there's pretty good evidence that
rats and mice can distinguish between
three different kinds of sweet basically
they can tell the difference between
long starch changes medium and short
ones and the scientist who's holding
this dr. michael toward off from the
Monell chemical senses Center is saying
nobody can figure out why this man-made
things should be so nice for a rat but
they love it right I actually ate some I
was like could I have some pali coast
please and it tasted like ground
styrofoam I got I had nothing out of it
and then this you know how I said it was
like astronomers after this discovery of
Jupiter this is this is Pluto this is
the thing that nobody can agree whether
or not it's a legitimate contender this
is a powder called coke Looney powder
and the people who are behind coke Unni
say they stopped short of calling it a
taste they say it's an effect or a
phenomenon and the idea is it is a basic
taste or a basic taste phenomenon that
makes the other basic tastes taste
better okay it's like nothing on its own
but it enhances the other so they say
make sweet sweeter salt saltier savory
savory and the people who are
researching it are
kind of researching it as a food
substitute additive could you make
things saltier without actually putting
a lot of sodium in the food now a lot of
scientists in the United States say this
is weird we don't get it this is their
they're like a Emperor's New Clothes
right but the company that's doing the
research for this as a Japanese food
company called ajinomoto which became
the first company to endorse and spread
the idea of Hammami and has been making
msg since 1909
so ajinomoto has a pretty amazing track
record of discovering six tastes in the
face of Western skepticism so I'll just
leave you with two questions regarding
the taste chapter and then I'm gonna
show you some biohackers right which is
what changed in our lifetimes that we've
been able to now taste umami it just
twenty years ago right most of us had
not heard of this thing now mommy's kind
of a fetish and aroma has anybody been
to a mommy burger it's a whole chain
based your honor mommy right umami March
in in Oakland right people who like
umami really like umami so what changed
what happened to us that in our lifetime
we adapted to it and then the other
question is how did it happen in Japan a
century earlier right yes right yeah
I've heard that you need an exemplar
right and in my book I argued that in
Japan the exemplars this thing that I
very poorly portrayed here which is a
broth called dashi right so I want to
show you really quickly something about
the search for a sixth sense I started
out with a growing house in their
basement and these are guys who are very
frustrated with the limitations of the
human body right they say look it's not
so great and if you had to engineer it
this is not what you would come up with
right they said it's a bad platform for
supporting consciousness
look you get sick you get die you die
Jim cannon who's the head of the
grindhouse said I would like my life
span to be decoupled from my bacon
intake right so this is Tim and then so
he's the founder one of the leaders of
grindhouse wetware this is literally the
grindhouse which is his basement and
when I met Tim they were working on this
concept called circadian so this is very
blurry picture of circadian on a
breadboard this is a better picture of
circadian a floor model our friend Otto
very kindly into it for us right the
idea of this is that it's a temperature
sensor so here at circadian Tim's arm
it's about the size of a deck of cards
and if I can make this work I will show
you what circadian does oops
I am
so he's charging it yeah so he's holding
a charge and coil up to his arm I asked
him to do it again because I moved the
camera but you can see there it goes
saying I got the signal so this
circadian was a test concept what it
does is it takes Tim's temperature and
it ports that information via bluetooth
to his cell phone right so he can kind
of look at it and go what's going on
right you might say what does that have
to do with sensory perception it has
nothing to do with sensory perception
this is basically to make sure that Tim
didn't die they wanted to see if they
could build it put it in his arm if it
would breach if something would leak if
you would develop a massive infection if
it would pop out of his skin you saw
it's it's pretty big it's close to the
skin the coroners are perhaps not as
rounded as he would ultimately have
liked it to have been all right but it
was it was kind of a trial device to see
if they could build it it took him about
three years he wore it for three months
then they realized that it was expanding
the battery was expanding due to the
heat of the charging coil so they took
it out also people asked me did they put
it in themselves no they went to a
professional piercer slash body mater to
do it so when I met them they were
working on something that really would
be a sensory perception hack they were
working on this idea for a device called
North Star and the idea for North Star
is that it would be a compass that would
go in the back of your hand and it would
light up when you faced north so that
was the idea so this is where they were
with North Star when I was there that
was it
wires and a soldering iron right this is
North Star maybe about a year ago this
was their first demo model you can see
it's about the size of a quarter this is
North Star ready for implant and this
was North Star this Thanksgiving so yeah
so this is Justin Wurst who sent us
these pictures he has it in his hand
this version lights up but it doesn't
actually have the compass element in it
that's going to be the next version so
that's where they are now they've made
it they've built it they're about five
or six people who have it and that's as
far as they've gotten so that's it
that's it for me I'd be happy to take
some questions if you have some
[Applause]
yes do you want me to yeah I'm gonna ask
you a couple things and we'll get some
questions from the audience so so as I
mentioned earlier I think what's one
thing that's really interesting about
your book is you you really go deep on
the science and you in a lot of
different Sciences but you're also
really channeling the personalities of a
lot of these individuals so is there a
take away on on who are the people that
are searching for this the scientists
and the biohackers is there what brings
them together is there is there
something that you would see you know
okay in all of them
so the the biohackers who were who were
well known to each other were brought
together by this kind of semi boiling
sense of frustration mostly right we
could be better but we're not not just
that the human body is and what they
would hoped but nobody was building the
stuff they wanted so grindhouse takes
its name from the dr. sleepless graphic
novel by Warren Ellis right which is
kind of about this like post-punk er
future where people build their own
augments because the future isn't isn't
cool enough right but um
but that's what this is not the case
with a lot of the people that who are
also researching in this field so
medical researchers are doing it because
they want to help people who have very
serious conditions for which there is no
other cure so I didn't talk it
specifically about them tonight but a
lot of the people who are doing sensory
research are working not only on
blindness and deafness but things like
Lou Gehrig's disease stroke locked-in
syndrome other things that would prevent
people from talking and moving and they
want to help now the thing is these
people do not talk to one another right
because there are insurance reasons why
people wouldn't want to talk to one
another they consider some of the stuff
that bio hackers are doing risky they
don't know each other when I showed a
neuroscientist this giant circadian he
said we could build that in my lab way
cheaper and way smaller and I said you
know that's cuz you have grant money
right these guys are doing it with zero
dollars so I felt my role in a weird way
was being like the plague rat who
carries ideas around
lab to love I've been going to say like
hey dr. so-and-so check this thing out
and maybe that's cool and then I'd say
okay how do you think it's working and
he'd say oh well it's probably this and
I'd go back to the grinders and be like
okay look dr. so he says what's going on
right so they're not talking to one
other and some people were very very
frustrated with this especially like
kind of in the piercer and body artists
world they were saying look like if if
doctors and surgeons would work with us
we could work safer we could do cooler
things we would have we would have their
their knowledge and and then of course
the bio hackers are also very concerned
that a lot of what's being developed
especially on virtual and augmented
reality is being developed for profit by
companies that will never share their IP
they'll never tell you how the device is
built what's inside it what its
capabilities are what its limits are so
yeah so basically it was we're silos of
people who are not talking to one
another so and so we're gonna open up to
questions here but let's let's just do a
quick tour so you went deep on a couple
chapters but you also looked at virtual
reality augmented reality all the senses
what's your because you're a your niche
is as a science journalist right and
that's I mean obviously you're really
passionate about that what's your own
science background and are you studying
up as you go or do you have a lot of
background on this it's just so I've
been a I don't have a science degree
have a sociology degree it's social
science degree but but not a
biochemistry degree or anything like
that I've been a science reporter here
in the Bay Area for about 20 years I was
at the East Bay express for a long time
I was at a magazine called terrain for a
few years which is sadly folded and I've
been doing a lot of freelance work in
there's more than a hundred people
interviewed for this book only six of
them were people that I'd ever met
before in my travel so I was really on a
huge learning curve which was fun for me
yeah so I was not playing to my strong
suit here okay what questions we have
out in the audience who's got a question
stumped rate you go questions here over
there we go there we going great we've
got a microphone for you you go oh and
and I should give a shout out to the
folks at home we've got
and and thanks to Edward Burtynsky
anthropocene film who are sponsoring our
livestream we've got folks listening at
home right now so the microphone helps
them hear your question - go ahead did
you run across any senses that don't
enter consciousness okay so one of the
arguments actually is that with taste
you sense things but they don't enter
consciousness right like you sense fat
subliminally and it never rises to the
level of consciousness there's a real a
lot of the last part of this book is
about bio hackers who are trying to see
if they can sense electromagnetic fields
a lot of animals have this gear that
lessens sense electromagnetic fields I
delve very briefly into do humans have
it have they ever had it do we even have
this kind of like vestigial sense of
electromagnetic field that is vaguely
related to that argument I don't I don't
buy it
personally but there are people who
who've asked if we have that for that it
and it's they're a bunch of touch tones
with other long now things and your
people leave that's big for us we had
the speaker last year who's whose book
or 2014 his book deep talked about
people with a collocation you touch
briefly on the fact that some blind
people have have used found to
echolocate how to do it yeah there's a
guy who has a school he will teach you
how to use he calls it hoe something
sonar but he uses like a click sound to
figure out where he is in space and
navigate around with it alright another
yep that reminds me
because that's basically built on top of
sound that I was taught at some point I
can't remember where that the other
sense was proprioception which is your
closer to your mouth design so that yet
so the question is is there another
sense called proprioception right which
is just so it's like the echolocation
which is the positions of things in a
room the position of your body relative
to the space all around it we're doing
our seats do people who study census
consider those higher-level aggregations
of census as census even because you're
not really conscious of it but if you
bump into things all the time it's
because you have bad proprioception yeah
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna seriously nerd
on you right okay so there is a concept
called range extension or range
expansion the idea is we're talking
about the same sense but some animals
have a bigger range right this is why
dogs can hear higher up the scale than
you do it's not a different sense it's
still hearing right when we're talking
about echolocation or bio sonar right
it's not a different sense they are
still using hearing they're just using
it in a way that humans do not naturally
do right you can teach yourself to do it
but it's not something that we're born
knowing how to do right now you bring up
the example of proprioception
proprioception means your sense of where
your body is in space
it's what light so you do this with your
eyes closed right I know where my arm is
so some researchers categorize that as a
subset of touch and there's this weird
wiggle room actually with touch
some people consider pain to be a subset
of touch as well in the book I make an
argument that actually it's what's what
I refer to as a poly sensory experience
or a meta sensory experience meaning
that it takes information from multiple
channels and creates this experience
that you have in your head and the
reason I argue that it's not purely
touch it's because for example a light
shining really bright in your eye would
be painful
a scientist said to me a gun shot near
your ear would be painful and those
aren't touch but it is pain right so
there's all these weird divisions about
how do you slice it and when I would
look at old textbooks they would slice
it up differently so I do think there's
it's moved around a bit but that was a
cool question
so my question yeah so we're able to
interview anyone that talked about
synesthesia or had experience with
synesthesia like what level do you have
those wires that get crossed are they
cross yeah man I wish I did that was the
chapter I didn't do actually there were
two chapters I didn't do one with space
because I did time and I thought and
time was pretty awesome we don't need
the face and then synesthesia would have
been the other thing right
does anybody here considers themselves a
senousy me too so like you would maybe
use like C colors associated with
letters or words very common form of
synesthesia so I'm not an expert and I
thought maybe that's somebody else's
book yeah so I didn't do it the closest
I got was I met a lot of bio hackers who
have these magnets implanted in them and
I would say what does that experience
like for you and people would say it's
kind of a synesthesia in that it kind of
combines elements of touch with elements
of something else
that I don't know how to describe that's
as close as I got to it so so you you
mentioned you're yourself as plague rat
the you are also like with the taste
thing your your navigating through
unsettled science in a lot of cases and
and flipping back and forth between all
kinds of folks that are doing is what
what would you say of the whole book is
there something in particular that you
that's kind of the aha moment that that
maybe kind of rising above just
reporting on things you may have you
come to any conclusions that beyond the
researchers as you're putting together
the different pieces of the puzzle
they're they're doing any examples of
that you know so one of the things that
kept coming up with this ethical
question of should we mess with the body
or should we invent devices that give
ourselves sensory superpowers should we
kind of keep human as human right and it
comes up a lot with I hear people being
late I see people thinking like yet no
yes or modify right this whole question
of what is a cyborg kept coming up over
and over so sorry I met a lot of people
who were very on the cutting edge of
cyborg Amite Rob Spence I Borg who has a
camera that's actually built into his
eye socket and I met a lot of people who
had implanted things in their bodies and
when I would ask them is it okay to
modify the body they say heck yeah it's
yours right you would do it if it was a
car right and then I would go talk to
other people especially from the
disabilities community where a lot of
assistive technologies go the
disabilities community first and they'd
say you have to be very very careful
about thinking about what you make into
a normal body right because
you keep raising the expectation of what
normal is and what a productive person
can do and there's a lot of coding built
into that right so I kind of kept coming
up against this question of are we
cyborgs or not where might you draw the
line a lot of the people in the kind of
pro cyborg community would say look you
wear clothes you wear shoes you are a
cyborg you're not built with them they
augment you against the weather this is
normal I started to think man there's a
lot of things that I've done to my body
even though I consider myself pretty
unmodified I've been vaccinated right
like I don't die when I'm exposed to the
to the measles virus I have eye fillings
in my teeth but I don't get cavities
anymore in those teeth you know and
nobody considers this very very
extraordinary and I think the the moment
where it kind of all crystallized for me
as I was talking to a guy who builds
smart glasses and he basically said look
we're at a point where we can self
evolve right if I'm gonna do something
that can give me an advantage that the
other guy doesn't have heck yes I'm
going to do it and he said this is what
humankind has done all along since
basically we tamed fire this is just
what people do right and I thought and
that's kind of where for me I thought
you know what it's not different it's
just it's more pervasive it's more
subtle you can wear it on the body you
can wear it in the body the main
question is not do we to be hacker
ourselves do we give ourselves
technology the question is when will I
get to the point where we've so subtly
altered ourselves that we don't know
that it's on right I think for me that's
the big difference and he go great I
have a two parter first what was the
most interesting VR related experience
that you had or you that you saw yeah
and secondly what do you want out of the
like what like haven't seen it what do
you where do you want it to go that's
cool okay so for VR I kind of had
experiences with two labs I wanted to do
this kind of hard super realistic
experience which was the military
experience where they really try to
simulate what it's like to be in combat
so in the travel lab I saw we just wore
goggles but if you went into their real
lab they would they would pump in smells
they would vibrate the floor to emulate
kind of driving motor shaking explode
and stuff like that and then I went to
this lab at Stanford called the virtual
human interaction lab which is like the
magic realism side of the VR world and
they are really inspired by Jaron Lanier
and kind of this idea of alternate
bodies so one of the things that I did
in there was they never told me what I
was gonna do they just said come to the
lab and I got there one day and they
said get down on all fours and wear
these like infrared markers they put him
on my back and they put him on my arms
okay fine
and they snapped on the VR and I was a
cow right and I was like okay what
they're experimenting with is Jaron
Lanier kind of famously asked this
question of why do you have to have a
human body in virtual reality right and
he said imagine that you're a lobster
okay you drive armed one with this arm
you drive armed two with this arm how do
you drive the rest of the arms right so
the question is how how well can you
adapt to these novel bodies so they put
me in a cow and I could see my cow
doppelganger across from me because it's
actually very hard to wear a helmet and
crawl around on the floor and look at
your own body at the cow body so they
did it we did all of these things that
kind of bonded me the cow do this and
the cow would do that I know you're
right and then they said okay here's
your job you have to gain all of this
weight so you reach a certain number of
pounds okay so I go over and I eat I go
over I'd and I drink and then they say
go back to your starting point because
now we're going to send you to the
slaughterhouse right and then the floor
starts to shake and this truck like it
starts making that beep beep beep backup
noises and I freaked out right I can
hear myself I have a tape of myself and
and in it I'm yelling this is brutal
right like that no one in particular and
viewer is like being on stage you're not
supposed to break the illusion you know
of the fourth wall I am really scared
and it's because basically I have come
to empathy emphasize with this other
that quickly right like I feel so
responsible for this other imaginary
being and that turns out to be what they
were trying to test in the real
experiment what they would have done
afterwards is kind of put me through all
of these batteries of tests to gauge how
I felt about animals and how likely I
was to donate to animal rights causes
and that was like that was a real
experience it was very visceral
and the other things that they did after
that is they made me a coral because
they wanted to see what how people would
behave in a body that's even more unlike
yourself so like I said like a seer see
you and then they did a thing where they
gave me a third arm and the idea was how
quickly would I learn how to drive a
third arm and I'll tell you it happened
like that it was ok so in VR the third
arm is coming out of my chest and I'm
wearing controllers on my wrist they
didn't tell me how to drive it they just
said make your third arm move
they said tap that thing it was just
like that it was an amazing experience
yeah did I answer all the yeah both of
these labs were trying to do things for
basically for pro-social reasons to help
people write to either prevent a
disorder cure disorder or kind of make
people more empathetic with their
environments with other people I thought
that was a really like awesome
application of VR they were talking
about using it for with students could
you bring students in and instead of
reading about global warming and the
effect on ocean life would you be able
to empathize with with ocean life I
thought that was a cool idea the big
question for me is how long does that
effect last right so I would love to see
more research that shows how long what
happens in VR lingers in your real life
that was an awesome question thank you
all right one more from right up here it
seems like in your talk you touched upon
what I think it's called the sapir-whorf
hypothesis which is that in order to
perceive something enough to have a
corresponding linguistic category and
I'm wondering if in your research you
looked into other language systems and
whether their categories of perception
resemble the ones that we use for taste
specificity so I only very only a little
bit and this is a good question and
people have also asked this question of
other sensory experience as well there
was a there's a
about emotion that says it makes it very
similar argument says can you feel
something that your culture doesn't have
a word for right can you feel
schadenfreude if you don't right so so I
did not do a comprehensive survey but it
did come up a few times with KOCO Kumi
this new idea that everybody is like
what do we get it it turns out that
there's actually another word Japan met
in Korean that appears to mean about the
same thing and the Korean researchers
were telling me look we're neighbors
with Japan and the reason we're not
talking about this we're not finding it
in our food is because we're separated
by this language and they thought the
reason that cuckoomy research is so
marginalized is because there's not a
universal word that everybody recognizes
that's as close as I got some of the
researchers that Monell said languages
tend to build words for the basics every
word every language has a word for sweet
every word has a language for salty
everything which has a word for salty
everybody has a word for bitter or bad
and in fact that's one of the arguments
against it is they say most languages
have not built a word for fat taste
maybe it's because it's not there all
right
so that's gonna do it for our Q&A but
you're not going away you're gonna stick
around here we've got Kara's book on
sale on the back you can come up and
just chat with her she's hanging out or
sign she'll sign your book right now
you're teaching right now you're not
working are you I am teaching
I am freelancing actually Abby Smith
Rumsey and I are going to be doing a I
don't know like a sparring match or
something like I know we're gonna be
we're going to be in conversation as
they cool March 10th that the mechanics
is - in San Francisco Oh wonderful place
and Abby's as you said speaking at the
at the end of the month here so that's
fantastic and that's my Twitter feed if
anybody would like to get in touch or
come come talk to me I'm the only care
of Latonia is great and and there's
still a lot of stories and a lot of
chapters we didn't even touch up yet so
please hang out talk to Kara a couple
other things one is we have a little
ceremony where I want to give you
along now challenge coins so thank you
for
[Music]
you